le grand moine Adrien pendant un moment là
tu résolvais une affaire majeure chaque semaine
je n'aurais pas pu le faire seul j'aurais
pu mais ça aurait pris
plus de temps j'ai des symptômes traumatiques
sans précédent dans l'
histoire psychiatrique il a le vertige c'est sa
deuxième plus grande peur  après les germes en fait
ça va germes aiguilles Oiseaux puis
Heights ce n'était pas un accident il a été
assassiné tu dois m'aider à tourner, tourner, tourner, tourner il y
a une bombe non, il
y a une bombe tu
n'aides pas nous devrions laisser une
note quand Co a frappé je  était en mauvais état, c'est à
moi, regarde-nous, vous tous, ils
vont détester ça, voici ce qui se passe, alors qu'est-ce que
ça fait de travailler à nouveau
comme faire du
vélo, je suis heureux d'entendre que je veux dire,
c'est
[Musique]
terrifiant